[Music]
[Music]
hmm
morning tinkers
oh no tinkles i can't
[Music]
a little privacy tinkles i swear
bad thing goes bad no no no
no
don't you have anyone else to play with
wait a second that's
it
[Music]
i have a little surprise for you
[Music]
oh don't worry what we need
is a monster dog like
[Music]
lollipop
[Music]
say hello oh booty
[Music]
he's not that weird
okay he's weird what about swampy
[Music]
next diablo
next spike
pebbles
heidi slithers sharky
whatever this thing is
next what
the last one oh boy this had better work
oh tinkles great news
i found you the perfect monster pet to
play with
say hello to your new best friend
sand
[Music]
oh it's a cat
stop
[Music]
[Music]
great now who are you going to play with
no oh no playing
[Music]
[Applause]
huh
here's to hotel transylvania
johnny works so hard to make this extra
special
fire
[Music]
ruined everything johnny what are you
talking about your dad never really
thought of me as part of the family all
because i'm not a monster
so you want to become a monster huh van
helsing
the muncification ray turns humans into
monsters and monsters into humans but is
this safe though
great question
that's weird nothing happened
hey drac what's up johnny
the nightmare it's over i'm human again
what's going on
[Music]
what's up fellas right oh i'm baldi
have you seen my
[Music]
we need to fix this now not a moment
away
[Music]
you're human now it's totally safe
it's wondrous it's
burning my eyes
[Music]
two